the Joe Rogan experience do you see this
[ __ ] with Justin Trudeau in the water
bottle did you see that tonight you do
put it up his but it wasn't today I saw
it today
did you see it earlier Justin Trudeau's
asked about how he and his family are
doing a better job at not using plastics
and his responses so she [ __ ] you know
awful you can't get it out he said well
we're using listen this [ __ ] this is
made me laugh so hard plastics we way
remind it one more you have the biggest
at least what you and your family do to
cut back on plastics we we have recently
switched to drinking water bottles out
of water out of when we have water
bottles out of a plastic sorry away from
plastic towards paper care how tired you
are now water out of a low do you
imagine if Apple somebody asked me a
question like that about my job imagine
if somebody said hey Joe what do you
think could be done to stop head trauma
and MMA and I'd be like well we could
conceivably there's not much but we
could pad the elbows we could pad the
knees we can I would have a thought I
want to [ __ ] thought that [ __ ]
through didn't think that [ __ ] oh and
there's also thinking about getting
caught in a lie did it I have plastic
everywhere I get home I saw his wife on
the bloom Oh on the way home coming for
us the house there's not a [ __ ]
bottle in the house it's all plastic
everything's play everything no glass
they throw with their Forks with every
meal the chicken foot he's sticking with
a see monkey cage feed him to Turtles
[ __ ] you
Joe's house is made of plastic this
whole house is plastic everything you
know he does he collects those little
things that six packs come with they
just Chuck's them in the ocean for a
laugh he goes to a lake it just puts a
bunch of [ __ ] dump killers out there
[Applause]